cobbles huge wedding halls are centers
of community life but the grand design
and decor of this one balai the carnage
of the attack
the death toll detailed in part by what
many of the victims left behind
throughout the night ambulances ferried
the injured for treatment outside of a
nearby hospital relatives checked for
names of the dead and injured an
attacker had set off explosives in the
midst of the wedding celebrations the
explosion happened near the stage where
the musicians were all of the young
people and all the people who were there
were killed some are wounded and now
they're in the hospital and others are
dead this nearby hospital needed every
bit of space to accommodate the victims
they had arrived in a massive wave of
distress we came to the site of the
blast and I saw that many women and
children were screaming and crying many
martyrs and injured people were
transferred by the ambulances and it was
really a terrible situation beyond the
weddings themselves wedding halls are
also used as simple meeting places for
small and large gatherings that's made
them the target of a local affiliate of
the so-called Islamic state last
November at least 55 people were killed
when a suicide bomber attacked hundreds
of Muslim scholars and clerics gathered
in another Kabul wedding hall to mark
the birthday of the Prophet Mohammed we
are joined now by freelance journalist
Ali and gala TV in Kabul Afghanistan Ali
who could be responsible for this attack
at this point it's hard to tell who's
responsible for this attack obviously -
still operates in Afghanistan the
Taliban have flat-out rejected any
responsibility calling it a heinous
attack saying that they absolutely
condemn such an attack but you know I
think it's really important to put this
kind of attack into contacts
as the video showed you know the fact
that the Bombers made it so close to the
stage means that they made it through
entire crowds of people these wedding
halls are giant structures where
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people gather in you know tables all
around centering mainly around the dance
floor and the stage where the performers
are so essentially you know the Bombers
have open access to hundreds of people
who had nowhere else to go the other
thing that you see in these structures
is as big as they are and as packed as
they are there's generally only one
entrance and one exit to them and
socially we have to remember that for
the average of on person I can't go
abroad who doesn't you know have access
to fancy parties who don't know
foreigners who throw these wild Rangers
and things like that this is really like
their one chance you know to to dance
and to celebrate and to sing and to have
some kind of enjoyment you know this was
like the one last vestige of something
like that and the fact that you know
it's come under attack this time in such
a heinous way you know it's also very
much a blow to to life in the city
because it's like the one form of
separation that people have yeah
let me ask you this as far as you can
tell I mean we've seen attacks like this
in the past in Kabul but as far as your
reporting can tell you was the wedding a
specific target or might that have been
targeting something else we don't know
yet because we don't know who's
responsible and and there's no
indication that you know this wedding
was specifically attended by any
specific person I can't imagine if they
went inside the building that you know
usually when they use a building to
target somewhere else they pick
high-rises and try and get to the roof
so for instance when a few months ago
during a time when they picked the
Ministry of telecommunications and the
essential post office building that's
because at one point it was the highest
building in all of Kabul so if they were
able to get to the roof they'd have
clear access
the presidential palace and so many
other important buildings in this case I
really think it seems to be sort of a
blow against morale you know it's also
coming as tomorrow's the 100th
anniversary of us regaining independence
from the British protectorate State and
you know there there have been flags and
pictures of King em on the law house
always thank you so much I'm afraid we
don't have much more time that's uh Ali
Latifi in Kabul first thanks so much